j'accueille maintenant jean luc
mélenchon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur mélenchon oui non non non non
ok en or at il tonné pas les tendances
assez cool brand un petit break cet
homme attend on va se recentrer
enfin marcher un peu et on va s'occuper
de monsieur mélenchon parfaitement au
[Musique]
personnage de plus triste de la soirée
je mets de la police
[Musique]
à
laval
[Musique]
problème
paris
[Musique]
remplaçants plein soir en place jean
marie c'est la fin d'un an mais tu te
crois où avant alors jean luc mélenchon
52 ans président délégué du conseil
général de l'essonne ministre sous
jospin cofondateur avec henri emmanuelli
de nouveaux mondes courant minoritaire
du ds voilà financier de 2 bat rapide
dans le sénat c'est pas leur nom le vent
je sais pas mélanger ces ballons je suis
pas tout autant pour moi je dis non
fondées avec emmanuelli le nouveau monde
autant pour moi je suis un type sérieux
nous bien sûr baril si l'usc est donc
plus généralement porte parole constant
jean luc mélenchon de la gauche
républicaine
d'ailleurs vous publiez un livre seul
qui s'appelle cause républicaine
mais avant je vais vous demander si vous
êtes passé de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année ouais ça va mais je ne suis pas
un mordu des fêtes je sais pas comment
vous dire ça parce que ça paraît
toujours un peu étrange mais je sais pas
ça s'est tout d'un coup c'est sorti de
ma vie se trouvait ça me fait suer cet
empilement de bouffe de deux sourires
russe de cadeaux dont les enfants qui
sourit tout le bonheur des enfants les
russes
[Musique]
l'été il a été sincère mais piste
anciens dans le mensonge et après les
dires c'est la langue de bois c'est très
bien vous avez été sincère dans le monde
social évidemment vous montez puisqu'on
est le le 18 décembre et les fêtes n'ont
pas encore eu lieu et que cette émission
et j'en ai aujourd'hui pour le 3 janvier
on voit que ça sera pas coupée au
montage
on voit avec cette erreur manque et tout
est bon à partir ou j 2 on voit comment
les hommes peut lui demander de vous
faire plaisir à tourner en bourrique
j'ai menti pour me faire plaisir c'est
vrai vous avez été sincère sur le fond
vous avez dit les fêtes ça me fait chier
et là il y avait un sentiment de vérité
dans ce que vous disiez alors est-ce que
vous avez pris jean luc mélenchon de
bonnes résolutions pour l'année 2004
houphouet je crois que je vais être
encore plus teigneux ah ouais ouais bon
vivant il était collé un peu j'ai déjà
arrêté de fumer
c'est dur un sas et c'est terrifiant
revient pour être plus ténue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais quand on quand on se fait
peut-être que c'est à cause de mon âge
donc ça se passe mieux quand on est plus
jeune mais ça dit que ça arrange ouais
ça détruit tellement le caractère on
s'aperçoit tellement con con me
manipuler que moi ça m'a mis vraiment
une grosse colère rétrospective de mire
je me suis fait manipuler le temps et tu
fais un crochet la drogue
ouais bah oui c'est comme l'hérault un
ol dur je sais pas parce que cette drôle
bas mais alors que les clubs y avait
partout dis moi tu sais tape à un peu un
peu mais l'ambiance est quand même
normal manger pour être honnête c'est la
deuxième fois donc la première fois je
m'étais manger 10 kg cette fois
seulement 5
elle vous me connaissez pas vous
commencez démoralisant amorce en france
c'est toi qui as raison jean les mêmes
trucs auxquels il va continuer encore ça
va c'est quand même vachement beau pour
mon prestige d'être la mieux pour vous
parce que
c'est un manuel et tente sa chance
ouais je revienne
non jean-luc avant de parler du livre on
va faire quelques mails de
téléspectateurs christophe wolkowitch de
paris 19e vous pensez quoi du blouson en
jean de fabius et je dois dire quoi la
gelée aggravé notre cas à tous bon ça va
alors je dis rien je rigole bien
alors on passe à daniel verrier de tours
faut-il porter des vestes en cachemire
si l'on est socialiste
ça c'est le méchant ça c'est koné le
truc c'est les socialistes sont tous des
menteurs d'être est bon ça va quoi je
préférais quand tu finis les nerfs des
fans clubs
j'en ai connu il va nous échapper des
fois ça me tente jamais j'ai été un peu
le rendre plus sympa des kilos en moins
et des années aussi annoncé que bien que
tu arrêtes de fumée s'est tu prends dix
kilos et bien du dit jeu vers fumée mais
tu gardes les dix kilos et que tu
arrêtes en reprend 10 noeuds roulante
règle de saint malo jean luc mélenchon
s'est vu déjà trompé vos électeurs si je
les fais ce n'était pas volontaire et
votre femme non aux basses et aux livres
on l'a sérieusement le livre s'appelle
cause républicaine au seuil que voilà le
pitch c'est simple c'est le retour au
parti puis républicain j'en avais assez
de d'être presque obligés de raser les
murs sur certains sujets par rapport à
toutes sortes de gens qui s'affirme des
racines des je sais pas quoi qu'ils
définissent d'abord par autre chose que
ce qu'on a en commun
et voilà je sais pas si c'est concret ce
que je réponds c'est concret je vais
expliquer pourquoi parce qu'en fait si
c'est très concret jean luc mélenchon
c'est arrivé en métropole
en arrivant du maroc en 1962 vous êtes
le petit pied noir
quoi tu arrivé en métropole les attaques
sur l'addiction parce que c'est pas le
même sens de la culture parce que
suivant l'endroit où vous êtes et à
l'époque on devait dire la métropole si
on disait pas la métropole ont passé
pension 10 et la france on vous disait
mais attends t'es gentil le maroc était
déjà des colonisés mes amis par exemple
il fallait dire les mêmes et c'était la
cohue à l'épaule a alors on était tous
là sur le sur les quais de gare où
l'équipe bateau bon moi j'étais môme à
je comprenais rien du tout à ce qui se
passe est sinon tout le monde avait
l'air affreusement malheureux et triste
est bon cette espèce de contact avec
avec la france qu'on avait nous on nous
l'avait médias lisez à mordre à la
maison disait en france en france tu
enfants enfin les routes sont tellement
bien fait que la voiture elle tourne
tout seul enfin c'est tout était bouche
détecter et tout d'un coup tu t'aperçois
que les autres veulent pas de toi voilà
d'accord donc alors moi j'étais le
[ __ ] et je sais même pas s'ils
voulaient m'injurier je crois qu'ils
connaissaient du maghreb que ça que
cette expression là donc ça m'a donné
une idée est ce que c'est que d'être un
immigré ouais c'était pas immigré
puisque je vois mon pays bien sûr vous
êtes dit toutes ces idées de racines de
terre alors là c'est toujours celle des
machines à fabriquer du malheur vous dit
et finalement vous décidé de revendiquer
une autre identité et dire ma tribu à
moi c'est l'humanité tout entière
mélenchon est devenu un citoyen la
pinterie ma patrie je dis c'est la
république parce qu'elle nous appartient
à tous parce qu'on l'a en commun parce
que elle elle nous permet à chacun
d'être là moi mes grands-pères et et ça
va vous dire quelque chose espagnol et
ça fait de moi un bon français
aujourd'hui dans cette dimension-là
règne de personnes sans envie de baiser
un d'accord
on essaie un peu sympa tu viens de nous
inventer ne voit pas arriver à nieul sur
ses comptes
le jeune le jeune mêlant chant donc
qu'un père espagnol se dit maintenant
crise et la république et là vous allez
commencer à à défendre bec et ongles la
république dès qu'elle est attaquée
alors par quoi la république était
l'attaqué et c'est vrai quand on lit
votre bouquin ça c'est inquiétant
on se fait un peu de villes pour cette
pauvre république parce qu'elle est
attaquée par plein de trucs le
communautarisme d'ailleurs alors on
parlera du voile islamique et tout ça
avec nous nos invités suivants donc la
promo on va pas en parler mais pour vous
déjà le communautarisme c'est déjà
l'enseignement des langues régionales à
l'école dans le fait qu'on enseigne
l'occitan en occitanie pour vous c'est
déjà une preuve d'obscurantisme quoi
j'ai surtout réagi très violemment à
l'égard des écoles elle enseigne dans
une autre langue que le français en
français
du matin au soir je considère ces de
l'enfermement et je vais vous dire bon
vous reprenez le scénario départ
j'arrive d'afrique du nord je suis quand
même pas le seul qui soit arrivé
d'afrique du nord d'accord il faut donc
il faut au hasard des villégiatures faut
apprendre la langue du coin et que celle
là ogle pas moi je sais pour rien mais
jus dans la passion qu'elle sent bien
des fois c est prendre club toujours
prendre
j'étais déjà comme ça avant la cloche
est alors la corse et elle il vous dit
en parlant de la corse pas donc la
possible dans la répulsion l'histoire de
messages de campagne
mais toi l'histoire le droit du sang
n'est pas dans ce cas précis dans
république l'histoire du droit du sang
des ancêtres de la coutume doivent pas
venir atténuer le principe d'égalité
voilà vous êtes le premier homme
politique que je dois dire ça vous dit
il vaut mieux perdre la corse que la
république si vous êtes prêts à ce que
la corse devienne indépendante
c'est à dire si ça doit être chacun sa
loi dans son coin moi je préfère perdre
un coin pareil que de perdre la
république est ma patrie parce que moi
j'ai que ça et la camomille essayer ça
calme la verveine s'emballe pour la
république non c'est pas des conneries
bon sens me fait peur il faut comme ça
autre côté niçois jean luc tu as changé
d'après du poids qui me regardent tout a
changé
[Rires]
il est le seul avec sa mère seule
adresse chez le court
alors donc la république est attaquée
par les communautarismes on vient de le
voir et bien entendu par le capitalisme
et ses suppôts alors c'est les
néolibéraux bien voulu changer mais les
sociaux libéraux c'est à dire tous les
blairistes du ps fabius je vais dire ce
qu'il faut que je dise et sa reine je
n'ai je ne je suis assez distant cierges
et en europe bien ça hein c'est pas mon
socialisme à moi voilà et moi je suis un
vrai partage
oui à partager soit un jacobin pur et
dur parce que ce qui est insupportable
c'est dans ce pays maintenant jacobins
c'est devenu un jeune âge c'est les
jacobins qui ont libéré le français
c'est la révolution que jacobine
alors maintenant la revanche est pris
par un paquet de petits minables qui
viennent jeter des pierres après que la
bataille soit fini et qui utilise ce mot
comme une injure la république est
attaquée par les communautarismes le
capitaine et puis l'europe alors tu dit
en parlant de l'europe
c'est une constitution sans assemblée
constituante en fait qui a été créé par
un club de coopter way et est plus
intéressant quand c'est la première fois
depuis l'urss qu'une constitution
proclame un modèle économique
vous savez j'ai vu il ya une page alors
moi j'aime pas ça on a le droit d'aimer
il ya une page il ya deux articles il
écrit quatre fois qu'il faut défendre la
liberté de la concurrence sans qu'elles
soient fausses et ça va insulter
institutions ça s'éteint c'est un
manifeste je suis libéral
c'est que la constitution européenne
qu'on voulait nous vendre la capitale
marché c'est une constitution qui
obligerait l'europe à être libéral pour
toujours pour toujours voilà et on
aurait rien eu à dire ça veut dire que
en quelque sorte faut bien comprendre à
côté de quoi on est passé à bombay ça
c'est l'envers de l'urss
c'est aussi peu des mots pareils
d'accord alors autre danger qui menace
la république le front national voilà
vous êtes carrément partisans vous de
l'interdiction vous dites que moi je
suis honnête je vais vous dire une chose
1 je pense que la république n'est pas
un régime neutre c'est un régime qui est
contenue un sens politique bon comme
vous êtes un vrai démocrate vous
accepter le fait que si vous êtes en
minorité quand les autres sont en
majorité ouais vous vous soumettez aux
lois qui sont adoptées bien qu' ici
accepte s'il ya une majorité dans une
assemblée qu'est front national de se
soumettre aux lois que votre aile front
national moi j'ai dit clairement à
l'avance pas moi donc je suis cohérent
un ces camps puisque je ne suis pas prêt
à me soumettre aux lois qu'ils
adopteraient donc je suis pour les
internautes ont révélé par ce parti
d'une pratique voilà qu'est ce que tu
dis c'est si en fait si le front
national arrive au pouvoir pas au
suffrage universel comme hitler était en
allemagne
moi je ne serais pas d'accord avec ce
qu'ils vont faire donc autant dire tout
de suite que je veux pas qu'il soit
autorisé parce que j'en ai assez d'être
régulièrement convoqués à aller voter
pour des gens parce que c'est mon
pouvoir démocratique on m'a volé quand
on m'appelle au 2e tour aller voter pour
monsieur chirac avant je suis socialiste
simplement pour éviter que l'autre fasse
plus de voix
c'est ma liberté qui a été volé déjà sur
jour là parce que moi j'avais pas envie
de voter pour cet homme c'est pas une
appréciation personnelle mais tout le
monde comprend ce que je suis en train
de dire donc on m'a volé déjà une
première fois ma liberté je ne veux plus
qu'on me l'a volé je ne veux pas faire
dix ans 27 ans facile on les sort comme
un épouvantail losc intervalle région
tout le monde sait qu'il est en train de
dire c'est quand même que vous êtes pour
le suffrage universel
sauf quand c'est vos ennemis qui gagne
quoi pas du tout parce qu'elles sont
c'est non écoute si c'est la droite
c'est pas mes amis je suis bien d'accord
avec pas d'accord avec leur vie dans un
monde
je suis d'accord à écrire mais là il
s'agit d'autre chose dont 100 ou alors
si c'est pas autre chose fallait le dire
avant il faut pas à chaque fois qu'il ya
une élection qui tourne mal s'amener
avec des têtes d'enterrement disant là
la catastrophe qui a danger il ya le
fascisme et ou si c'est vraiment le
fascisme se défend jean marais dans le
clip qui va décider
qui se présente ou pas à ce moment là ce
que tout le monde peut se présenter à la
présidence qui veut des systèmes actifs
en place de caen ce cas pas des mecs tu
as des mec t'as déjà du front en scène
nationale light tas de la droite un peu
dur tu as du machin tu as un peu tout
elle est où là les mecs qui vont vouloir
rallier à venir l'extrême gauche à ce
moment là j'ai aussi des gens bien des
gens du qatar n'a rien à voir il ya des
gens à l'extrême gauche alex je suis
allé sur le moyen d suis pas d'accord
pour obéir à des lois faites par un mec
d'extrême-gauche a pas du tout l on lui
interdit donc obligés de
non mais attendez moi je ne suis pas en
train de faire le tour du monde je parle
d'un clavier tu la merde j'en les noms
moi j'ai valeur a résidé après tu sais
plus tant qu'on y est non non non tu es
le front national c'est la légende à
sérieux parce que vous mettez sur le
même plan des tâches aux cons rien à
voir et vous faites comme si c'était
pareil je m'excuse d'arlette laguiller
le pen c'est pas pareil
et ben moi je suis ça c'est pas moi de
dire ça je ne laissais pas pareil pas
d'accord alors si c'est pas pareil on
les met pas d'accord
bon on a quand même n'ont alors pas
sortir l'autre que je veux en clair jean
marie dailland la dite moi qu'il fallait
me fusiller donc ça va c'est très bien
qu'ils ont un décor aussi
moi si j'étais le jour où vous m'aurez
comme premier ministre j'interdirais le
front national car cela mais seulement
que l'envoi de la haine non plus
maintenant
quand on est passionné il paraît que ça
s'arrête a intéressés c'est vachement
grave quand même ce que tu dis pas ce
que ça veut dire que par exemple la
question pour un artiste d'aller jouer
ou pas par exemple dans une ville qui
est front national donc d'après si je
suis ton truc c'est pas compliqué toi tu
y vas pas à tant d artiste tu vas jouer
le bas ou pas je sais pas
enfin moi aussi j'ai hâte en moi je
demande que changerait parce que dans le
double avec même dans n'importe quel
corps humain il ya un coeur et il ya
quelque chose à lui met dedans si c'est
pas ces laves leur petite flamme d'amour
allait peut-être en veilleuse mais il
faut y aller et venir
avec les bons choix de ce que dira un
tiers dans cette ville alors on y va
moi je sais pas je sais pas répondre
parce que j'ai tendance à penser que
comme vous au départ en faisant toute
façon aux gars il va venir il va faire
vibrer quelque chose de fort mais sur le
terrain il faut que tu es ce que
racontent les gens parce qu'à défaut et
10 venez d'autrefois et 10 n'ont en fait
pas ça parce que vous nous enfoncer
encore plus c'est comme un tour il
apparaît couleur du maillot sur un champ
de bataille tu vois un mec qui va crever
j'essaye de soignies et essaye de faire
qui meurt pas même si c'est un ennemi et
la tnt un toubib sauvé pour guérir
tu va griller pas touché parce qu'il
opère dans tous les cas non t'enlever a
qui me concerne j'avais leur âge mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai tout ce que moi
je verrais bien tu veut interdire le
front national est parti pour les cas tu
poseras le couteau pour couper je
devrais savoir où tu le pose parce que
ce mec vachement dur de savoir où le
poser mais non un peu avant a besoin
après pas si dur c'est son truc pression
pour demander de quels signaux qui
resterait que deux parties par exemple
c'est un tu me rappelles une réflexion
de même un chauffeur de taxi un coup et
j'ai tourné très très drôle
il me dit moi je suis tolérant mais pas
plus et c'est terrifiant de détrôner
rang mais pas plus alors qu'ils pensent
que j'ai fort mais je pense que tu vas
avoir du mal à trouver l'endroit où qui
va mettre le couteau pour couper et où
et sait où qui veut mettre le truc c'est
quand tu vas dire non à présent que le
front national est il veut supprimer
juste le front national mais il va
arriver un autre parti arrêt qui quand
on demande aux mecs pourquoi vous n'avez
pas interdit de francs la chaîne indice
parce que ça va être le national front
qui va arriver d'assurance
avoir regretté pas de pas voir interdit
leur nom ça vous dit rien
non mais je vous dis juste ça comme ça
parce que là on discute en général moi
je sais que j'ai retenu de ggp a une vie
si j'ai en plus j'ai du [ __ ] dans une
génération où il n'y a pas eu d'immenses
drame n'a comme les générations d'avant
sont tapé une guerre des choses comme ça
mais le peu que j'ai vu ça m'a au moins
appris ça c'est que les sociétés sont
fragiles et quand elle dérape
elles vont jusqu'au bout personne
n'aurait dit que les gens les
s'entretuer en yougoslavie comme ils
l'ont fait et chaque fois qu'on laisse
aller
qu'on laisse des gens comme ça se mettre
en place et danser la catastrophe
derrière moi j'ai pas envie de ça pour
mon pays
donc comme je suis quelqu'un de
conséquents et de cohérent que cherche
pas à faire plaisir mais à dire ce qui
me paraît juste pour la patrie
républicaine je le dis cela pour les uns
d'accord bon là alors jean luc mélenchon
très bien on est le 3 janvier comme déjà
elle est incroyable non j'espère qu'on
est là les fêtes je fais et les 3
janvier alors là bon c'est même pas
embrassés pour l'abonné
[Musique]
l etat
et on peut
c'était la pause les joue assez agréable
le mien je tenterai les huit mois j'ai
eu le sien j'ai eu le vôtre olivia oui
mais a attendu parce que hélas les
médias je propose bisous avec la langue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
agaçant bord de mer
[Musique]
laurent laurent bon alors moi j'ai bien
alors c'est super agréable chez pas
diallo on va faire une pause pénétration
[Rires]
bien
[Applaudissements]